"A dream is a wish your heart makes" is from Walt Disney, and from Cinderella.
That is Cinderella's Castle.
It's not true, of course; a dream is a random firing of neurons that your brain is trying to interpret,
but it's a lovely saying.
And there are people called oneironauts
—that's the technical term they've come up with—who are dream explorers,
people who do lucid dreaming.
The idea that you can, sort of "wake up" in your dream,
be aware that you're dreaming, and then control whatever you want:
fly, talk to people, beat fears, whatever you want to do.
Now, I've tried to do this in the past; it's not been terribly successful for me,
but one of the things I did learn is something that you might not know, which is how to tell if you're dreaming.
There's a check you can start doing a couple of times a day,
that is, apparently, quite a good trick to learning to lucid dream.
And the simple test is this: read something.
Read anything, the words on a sign, a newspaper, whatever you want.
Not only will they not make sense, but they will change every time you look away and look back at them.
They'll just be whatever words that your brain happens to come up with,
from everything in the dictionary, utter nonsense.
Whatever your brain happens to come up with, whatever neurons in the language centres of your brain happen to fire,
those'll be the words you read.
So, if that happens, look down at the thing in front of you right now,
I mean, I'd imagine that computers don't work in dreams, either, and that's another good sign.
So either you're dreaming, or you're running Windows.
But, basically, look for words. See if they change,
and if they do, well... don't try and wake up,
try and have a bit of fun first.
That's lucid dreaming and that is something you might not have known.
I think I found Donald Duck(!)
[Translating these subtitles? Add your name here!]